[音楽]
あったけこんにちははめ社長
です
いや服が塗れないか心配
です私ですね今練り枠にあるサンライル
サーカスという施設のスパスパのこの大
浴場大きめのお風呂に来ておりますいや
なかなかこのサイズのお風呂は家にはない
しめっちゃゆったりできそうでいいなって
思いながら今足してますでお風呂といえば
皆さん入浴剤ご存知でしょうかで見て
くださいこの今お風呂この大浴場のお水
めっちゃ無職透明なんですよすごい綺麗な
んですけれどもお風呂に入る時よく入浴剤
に入れてこのなんかいい香りとか匂いとか
楽しんだりして入る時ありませんか私が
今回この大きなお風呂でやってみたいこと
こちらご覧ください
[音楽]
なんか目に入った入浴剤全種類買いまし
たいや多いななんかそのネットとかお店で
売ってるとりあえず有名どころというか今
売ってる目に入った入浴剤を全種類買った
ところを124種類入浴剤ありました見て
くださいもう有名のところのバスロマンと
かバブとかもなめっちゃ種類があったん
ですけども全部買いました今ここに多分
日本に売ってるニューヨク剤ほぼ全部ある
かと思いますというわけで私が今回したい
ことは入浴剤全部混ぜたらどうなるのやっ
てみたいと思いますバスボムとか全車に
混ぜたとかあるけども小さいスケールが
小さい乳剤全部混ぜたらどういう行動が
あるのかそしてどういう香りになるのか
あの色も気になりますねめっちゃカラフル
でしょこれ混ぜたら多分すごい綺麗なお
風呂になると思うですよ今回すごいですよ
乳剤全部混ぜた時の高能そして色香り
間違いなく市上最強のお風呂ができるので
ただこの量全部ぶっ込むとさすがにお家の
お風呂ではできないので今回こういった
大きなお風呂をお借りして撮影してるわけ
でございますでは早速入れていき
ましょうはいじゃは早速混ぜていき
ましょうまずはやっぱりなんかお風呂と
いえばこれ聞いたことありますバス
ロマン入れていきたいと思います大きいね
30回分入ってます
全部入れます嘘ですあのさすがにあの1回
分よりちょっと少なめにしましょうかこれ
まず全種類にこの量入れてると俺多分死に
ます粉浮いてきそうな気がするんでさすが
に適量入れさせてください1回分120
なんか入れたも多分やばいと思うから
ちょっと少なめに入れていきたいと思い
ますちょっとマジでやばい普通に繰り返す
乾燥肌にしっかり潤い仕ヒアルロ産とか
入ってるどうなっちゃうんだ俺あもう高能
やばい疲労回冷し荒れし汗も失ニキビキ
しもやけ赤肩の腰血流地内くじき335の
ヒシめちゃくちゃ効くやん全部入れたらこ
のすごいことになりますよどうなっちゃう
んだろうな色も気になりますね記念すべき
1個目行き
ますこんなもんでいいんじゃないこんな
もんでいいんじゃないかな入れすぎると
さすがに俺普通に多分毒で
死ぬこんな感じちょ入れていこうと思い
ますまずはバソロワン全部入れていきたい
と思いますバソロワンだけもすごい種類
あるからなバソマンプレミアムボタニカル
スキンケア種類のボタニカル保湿成分入っ
てますねこれマジで肌スルスになれそうだ
な嬉しいあ緑色結構色すごいな結構結構色
来てるなバサルマスキンキアダブルミルク
プロテインえ俺今日筋肉もけえられるんだ
プロテインとかも入っちゃうのかなあ
白いめっちゃミルキーバスロマンスキン
ケアダブルセラミドほえ肌荒れ出身に効き
そう
です
ああ
バスロイド最近見ますね体の芯まで温まる
という汗かきやすくなる入浴剤なんかね
よく見る気がします最近らあオレンジ色
バトロマンニオ桜の香りわいい匂いしそう
こういうの絶対いい匂いしそうだなあ
ピンクバサロワンプレミアムモイスト
スキンケア美容液成分10種類入って
るってあちちちちえ俺大丈夫だよねや
やばくないなんか効
か最強のお風呂作ってるぞ白バスまひのき
の香りひのきはもう匂いがいいですから
うらおおオレンジロ黄色いなはい皆さんお
気づきでしょうか湯舟がかなり白くなって
きましたいろんな色入れてるけどやっぱ
なんか入力剤って白いのが多いなまだ
ちょっと薄い感じがしてますねどんどん
入れていきたいと思いますバスマン
ほっこりの香り
ああ
スパイシーえ蛍光塗料なの蛍光塗料みたい
なやだけど大丈夫かこれパバスマンふわり
桃の香りあ無天下なんだいいね可愛い
パッケージですねらおおバルマン
メディテーションタイムメディテーション
タイムってなんだ瞑想欲ですってなんか
こう安らげるのかならわすごいスライム
カラーや色がすごい特徴的だなこれで
バスン全部入れ終わりましたなんかね
いろんな色入れた気がしたんですけども
結果的に綺麗な白色になってますまだ全で
も薄いですねはいどんどん入っていこうと
思いますポッピンアロマ2種類ありますね
こんな可愛いのも今あるのねはいはい粒
タイプのやつ
だ
あっつちょっと待ってめっちゃ汗書いてき
たんだけど八巻効果めちゃやばい多分
めちゃくちゃ泡が出るんだろうな行って
こいおお
ああいい匂いだ泡が立ってくるんでしょう
か分かるかなちょっと泡が出てきてますね
おおグレイトバースリカバリーア
トリートメントこれね俺昔入ったことある
んですけどもめっちゃ良かったですなんか
これめっちゃ売れてるって聞いたことあっ
てとりあえず買ってみたんですけど
めっちゃ疲れが取れた記憶がありますでも
色とか匂いとかなくて本当にただの能が強
いってやつですハニーバミルなんか蜂蜜
そうめっちゃ全部入れると死にそうなので
ちょっと
だけあ甘い蜂蜜の香りうん温泉ジャポン
ジャポン4種類ぐらいあるので全部一気に
入れます中身どうなってんだどういう中身
なんだあしっかり粉のやつ
ねおおおおおおすごい色がミルクバスら
メリークリスマスなんかサンタの贈り物
みたいな入浴剤ですねほああ
いい
匂いすごいワインみたいな匂いするうわ
なんかそろそろ色が変動してきそうだな
プレゼントforyouまたサンタ
シリーズかあこれはああスライムカラー
ねねすやすやの香り寝れるやつだなお
スライムカラースライムカラー多くない
どうしよ最後スライムブロになったら
マリーゴールドほうわオレンジ色頑張ろう
シリーズはあ何これあなんか明日もまた
頑張ろうみたいな毛穴の汚れを効果がある
んだってこの風呂入れば何でもかるなロリ
フィンランドバスソークおらわ青い青い
スモバスソルト
何何何どういう香りな
のああこういうタイプね赤い気がするな
ああ紫色かいいじゃん招き猫の湯うら青い
なんか
ねザラザラしてきた床がだるまの湯らセジ
原ジあ入れきたまずいまずい
やば浴が緑色なってきてる気がするんだ
けど大丈夫でしょうか疲れた体にパワー
タフプロ疲れとけねぐっすりサポーター
グーズピーミルカホワイトテーおらうお
めっちゃピンクだグーズピーホワイト
ブーケほいわピンクグースピーベルカボタ
のスイートオレンジおらうわオレンジだと
思ったミルキー入浴剤お菓子っぽい入浴剤
ってちょっといいよね白いああめっちゃ
ミルキーの香する来ましたバス
ボムなんかお風呂とえばみたいなとかあり
ますよね
うわあいろんな種類がありますねこれ1個
ずつ入れたら俺しいやこれさすがに
バスボム全部入れると結構やばい気がする
んですよねさすがにお風呂大きいと言って
も本当に濃くなっちゃうのでちょっと心配
ですなのでちょっと1個ずつちっちゃくね
こう小刻みに少しずつ入れて安全に入り
たいと思います
うら終わったバスボのなんか違うやつ
[音楽]
手がぬるぬるで赤お
おおカラフルですねいやバスボムはマジで
これ全見れると本当に水が単なくなるんで
さすがに少しずつ入れます
[拍手]
うら全部入れちゃったバスボも入れると
結構色すごいことになりそうなんで
ちょっとこれで放置してみたいと思います
バスボム入れてみてちょっと時間受てみた
んですけど結構色変わりましたねあのその
あまり言いたくないですけどもその泥水
泥水みたいな色にはなってきましたねまこ
小物はありそうですめっちゃ体にはさそう
なのでどんどん入れていこうと思います
日本の名日本の温泉の入浴剤ですね初種類
の温泉が入ってるみたいです
黒川レップ
州
竜神
やニトおすい
ニゴおいやいやキャンディやんこことか
すごいなここに日本の全てが詰まってます
登りたはい日本の温泉コンプリートなく
なって気がするな日本の名もう1個さっき
の8種類にプラスして10種類増えてるの
でその10種類入れていきたいと思います
るとこがぬるぬるになってきたけど大丈夫
かえ皆さんちょっとご覧
くださいたくさんたくさん入れたんです
けども
あの
なんかすごい模様になってます大丈夫
か小柄になった
けどただ床加減はいいので多分大丈夫だと
思います続行きましょう川おら宮城の
なるこ野沢おらひし
湯原うえドゴうわうしのおおナス塩原う
シジ熱これで日本の温泉はコンプリートだ
と思いますあかう結構色がすごいことに
なってきましたね聞きシリーズこれもね
なんかよく聞くやつですねうわ
すごい6種類あるのかな高能がそれぞれ
違いますねカサれに腰肩こりにあやばい
冷し疲労肩こりと疲労回復ザラ肌出身疲労
肩こりよしよしよしよしバスラマン薬
シリーズほぐしオおおきれ硬いたりオぺ
ぺぺペペペ
あもう粉がすごいおおいいねボトリタ酸4
種類の香りが楽しめますねバラ蜜くみ明し
蜜レゲ蜜音符缶キッチシリーズみかゆキカ
ゆ溶岩ゆすだちゆオポこだわり生姜なん個
あんねんなん個あんねんこのシリーズ
ありがとうゆずとし蜂蜜ハード音こだわり
森シリーズすごいデパート多いな太陽死に
ず余わかば法こだわりシリーズホニが
ほこり完熟立て法シリーズ入れてからまた
夢の色が変わってきた気がしますねなんか
黄色味が出てきて本当なんか高能のある
温泉感出てきまし
たぬるぬるしてますファインヒート
シリーズええなんかこれ良さそう汗かくの
かな4種類ありますパッケージ可愛い
おらやばい下が
もう石畳みになってる
ぞあ待てて脇出てるんだけどここから
すごいなめっちゃなんか水力
がえ
すごいりすぎたなコアラのマバスボールき
ましたこのシリーズおもちゃが中に入っ
てるやつねコアラの街のおもちゃが入って
ますあでこのゴリールの中つかるかな呪術
回線コントマスコットさっきのやつの呪術
回線バージョンですねおお行け
スプラトゥーン3バスボール美味しそう星
のカービーバスボール絶対ピンクだ絶対
ピンク
だ今こんなのもあるんだ昆虫バスボール中
に昆虫が入ってるみたいですねえ可愛い
これは嬉しいわあとちょっとでかい行って
こいあああもうもうもう溶けてる通りゆあ
カービーのも早いデデデコアラのマおお
可愛いイカ昆虫も出てきましたちょこう
いうのやっぱり楽しいよ
ねはいみなどうもほとんどの浴剤は入れ
終わりましてあとはこのバブシリーズバブ
のシリーズだけが入れてないという状態
です色もねも結構なんだろう緑っぽくなっ
てきたんですけれどもこれ1個ずつこう
ちまちま入れてても色の変化楽しめないと
思うので最後はバブシーズを全部まとめて
1つにしてバーンて入れて市上最強の入浴
剤全入れのお風呂を完成したいと思います
バもめっちゃ種類あるので早速全部混ぜて
いきたいと思いますでは行きましょう
バブル私服の鼻めぐりゆ4種類入ってます
種類バブ私服の柑橘ミグあこれも4種類
バブ私服の森めぐりゆ4種類バブ私服の風
めぐりゆ4種類ちょっと入れてみよう反応
させときたいなおおめっちゃ
綺麗ええやないすかバブぬくもりナイト
おらバブホカすっきりバブ爽リカバリー
バブハカリフレッシュ
やばい
流しバブクールバブクールオリエンタル
スパーバブクールバブエクストラクール
バブナイトアロマバブミマバブビーブバブ
モンスターバブルバブモンスターバブル
バブモンスターバブル溢れるのはきっとお
だけじゃないバブバブバブバブバブ
バブバブはいバブ全部入れ終わりました
バブめっちゃ綺麗だ
これ全部出たらまた絶対色変わるしなか
鮮やかな色になるそうな気がするカラフル
なお風呂の完成やはい皆様お待たせしまし
たバブ全種類ここにありますいやもう
めちゃくちゃカラフルなんでこれをこの
濁った緑色のお風呂に入れた瞬間絶対
カラフルになること間違いなしじゃあ早速
全部入れたいと思いますこれが全ての入剤
せた最終済だ行きます
[音楽]
ちょっと放置しといてみよう絶対カラフル
になります絶対間違いますさあ果たして
何色になってるんでしょう
か変わら変わらないあんなにカラフルなの
たくさん入れたのにあんまり変わってない
ぞ結構もう反応しきってるのでこれ以上色
が変わることはないと思いますが
えっと入浴剤全部お風呂にぶち込んだ
ところえこんな色になりました
え迷彩グリーンみたいなあのアメリカ
ザリガニとかいりそうな色だと思いますが
まあなんか有名どころの温泉ってこういう
色してますよねうん色はまあまあなんと
なく想定ないというかこんな感じかなと
思いましたそして匂い匂い
が
[音楽]
あ何これなんて表現したらいん
だ
んえマジでわから
んいろんな思いが詰まってますねフルーツ
とかなんかひのきと
か甘いものとかいろんな匂い入ってるん
で表現しづらいな俺もずっと匂いかき続け
てきたんでちょっと判定できないんで
ちょっとこの匂い知らない人入らせて何の
匂いか当ててもらいたいと思いますこれね
俺じゃない方がね匂い分かると思い
ます来ましたお来たかはいよし来い
[音楽]
はいえおお来たか来たかはいよしたさお
風呂あるからちょっと入ってみてもらい
ていお風呂ですか
うんはいあたけはいどうぞどうぞ
あったかいだろどうぞはいあたいはいはい
はい気持ちいい気持ちいいすすかこれ
めっちゃいいじゃないですかめっちゃいい
しょめっちゃいいっす今その堪能してて
くれはいよしえサさんあはいじゃ匂いと
その目ではいあなた何に入ってるかはい見
てみてくださいわかりました行きますはい
えもうこれ普通にパってどうパって言はい
行きますはい行きます
はい
うわあ何これ
[音楽]
飛ぶ
どぶ色はどこだけど匂い
どう匂いはいい匂いという
かいい匂いすね本当これサビのお兄ちゃん
の出汁から取ったお風呂です汚たな嘘嘘
どうだ分かるいやちょっと頑張る頑張る来
た来た
かわかんないいっすささんこれはい
入浴剤全部入れました全部全部入れました
すごい色すねいい匂いだけどまさに言った
通りで表現できない匂いなんですそうすね
なんかもうもはや臭いみたいなねか
ちょっとねいい匂いなんですけどこの世も
に例えられないような本当に全種類入れ
ないと分からないような匂いだと思います
はいでえっとたくさん入れたんでぬ剤て
高能があるじゃないですかあはいはいこの
お風呂の高能すごい方ありますよマジすか
このお風呂の高能疲労回復おお冷えし肩
残り腰板神経龍地荒れし汗もしニキビヒ
しもやけ赤内見くじえ335の冷え
し普通だななんか普通なら多分どの入力剤
も同じような能なるかもしれないですね
なるほど全部入れたんですけどもこのお
風呂のコーはこういう感じになってます
このお風呂はねもうオレンジの大きさだと
絶対無理だったので大きいお風呂じゃない
とできなかったということでちょっと
あまってから帰ろうと思いますはいバイ
バイオケちょっと足かくなってきたんです
けど大丈夫ですか